good in a room is a common Hollywood
term that agents used to describe their
clients who present themselves well so
it's a general business book as far as
for anybody who is pitching their ideas
to their boss or interviewing or wanting
to pitch a creative project or sell
their services but with Hollywood
stories to make it interesting of course
one of my favorite projects was that I
supervised was the movie Legally Blonde
and so that was a project that I worked
on from the very beginning of developing
the script and working with the cast and
mainly developing the script was my main
project but that was something that I
really enjoyed and learned a lot from
when I was an executive at MGM I looked
so much to hire playwrights and people
writers who had graduated from theatre
school because I knew that they actually
understood structure and understood that
creative project should have a beginning
middle and an end which for most people
isn't commonly taught apparently or they
just didn't understand the same sort of
classic structure that we were certainly
taught here and then I find really
valuable so as much as I could hire
playwrights or people from theatre I did
I think that there aren't that many
universities that really are doing such
a great job of creating leaders and
creating real visionaries and being
supportive to artists to be able to take
risks Carnegie Mellon far outshines I
mean far far outshines as far as their
preparation for the real world
encouraging people to have internships
encouraging you to have professional
connections before you leave school
there's absolutely no comparison